One of the things about hunter that's really intoxicating is that his sort of
self destructive path becomes romantic when you read it and you get involved in
his work and you kind of mimic it,
you know,
it's uh,
that's the greatest fallacy I think.
I think what he was trying to say with self destruction was that this was an
incredible threat to our American democracy.
Not,
I don't mean that,
I mean,
I mean his,
no romanticism teaching his,
well,
I mean the romantic aspect of it was that his work was fantastic.
I mean,
window was till it wasn't,
it was fantastic till it was,
it wasn't,
I mean he understood,
he didn't feel it was,
but he lived in with,
he spent much more time within the consequences of that pinching than he did
within the success of the bingeing.
Right.
And that I think he knew that it has letters.
It's really beautiful and heartbreaking.
And in his writing too,
I mean,
I think that's what's been missed about him is there's no romanticism and self
destruction right.
Towards the end.
He definitely lost his productivity.
And Yon Warner talked about that in the Alex give me documentary.
He just sticky fingers.
It was a great,
the document,
uh,
the new book on the New Book on Yon Winner has great moments of Thompson,
the 70s just being kind of lost.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think,
I think we got to remember that we have an incredible times in American history.
We have times that are going to burn brightly and it's up to each rider to
decide how they'd like to burn next to it.
And if you're going to burn brightly,
they may not have other times.
And that's I think an American thing where you can wager that bright flame,
which means you may have nothing left afterwards,
but Thompson knew that he may have to live in that kind of afterlife.
I want one.
Thompson writes about it so beautifully.
Um,
stories,
I tell myself there's some footage of him when he was writing for,
I forget what newspaper somewhat was it somewhere in the Pacific northwest.
What are ways you're writing for?
Who is the author of playing off the rail?
Google.
Uh,
playing off the rail.
There's a guy who was a journalist,
but year,
do you think it was David Mccumber?
Yes.
David [inaudible].
David McCumber employed hunter for a while when David was,
um,
I forget what publication he was working for,
but there's some footage of them community to communicate together and you know,
it was trying to get,
hunter has in San Francisco was in San Francisco and hunters out of his fucking
mind.
I mean it was younger.
You mean he wasn't even that old,
but he was just wrecked.
He just couldn't communicate.
He couldn't talk and uh,
you know,
he made a beat.
He makes the beast have you escape the pain of articulation.
You escape the pain of saying this is what's wrong in American society.
For him to say the way he did,
one of his great essays is from 1964.
It's by going to Hemingway's Ketchum,
Idaho.
I'm grave and Hemingway's house and it,
it's gorgeous because it talks about Hemingway was a good writer,
one of the best writers.
And when he was writing about an up period,
he understood the 1940 [inaudible] 1930s,
when there was a firmness to the reality that he could articulate.
One of the goals is to give a pattern to chaos,
is to give an articulation of CAS.
But what happens in the 1960s when the chaos is multiplying repeatedly,
somebody like Hemingway becomes a literal relic.
Like his narrative no longer fits into the present that he's in.
And Thompson saw Hemingway's decline and he wrote about Hemingway's,
um,
uh,
suicide by his narrative doesn't fit Hemingway's idea of what America was and
what a man should be fit perfectly with what I think w the twenties to the
forties when we experienced.
But I think in the early 1960s with our social upheaval of civil rights,
of,
um,
you know,
political upheaval,
Hemingway,
it was confusing to them.
It didn't,
it didn't fit anymore.
Like his way of operating no longer articulated the presence.
And so Hemingway's last act was to take away his ability to say anything at all.
That was his only the last thing we ever said was to stay,
I'm not going to say anything anymore.
Was the suicide that Hemingway committed and Thompson wrote about that core?
Justly.
Yeah.
When,
when I was young,
when he wound up killing himself,
it was almost unsurprising,
you know,
when,
when I read that he had died,
I remember going,
Oh man,
well I guess,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
it's like you knew that he was deteriorating rapidly.
You knew that he had really bad hips.
He had had hip replacement surgery,
um,
the Ralph stepping leg.
Yeah.
Ralph Steadman had drawn this very crazy image of him with the artificial hip
and yeah,
it looked like pain,
you know?
I mean,
but I think that it's not my place to even deal with that because Juan
Thompson's book writes about that moment where one Thompson was in the house and
that's,
that's his,
and one writes beautifully about the stakes of it,
how painful it was to the people that loved him chorus.
Everything about it.
Um,
and how that even if that's a logical outcome at that's not,
no,
it needed it.
So it's interesting,
I would say read stories.
I tell myself that moment is so honestly and brilliantly written by Warren.
No,
I'm sure.
But Bama,
oh,
I was getting at is that at the time of his death,
you know,
he was in to sort of,
uh,
the,
he was deteriorating so badly.
He was wearing diapers.
His,
his entire cause of his alcoholism has ability to control.
His bladder was gone.
And so one gave this wonderful speech at George Mason when he came out and he's
like,
how do you write honestly about your father?
And he asked the question of like,
should I include this detail?
And he's like,
if my father was alive,
I couldn't include that.
But that's why I chose in a sense to write my book where my father was dead
because I think my father would want me to write honestly,
but also not want me to clue that if he was still alive.
And so he included that detail and he talked about that,
the struggle to include that detail,
which I think brilliantly articulate what you're saying,
which is the deterioration in the sadness of it.
And I mean,
we have finite amount of energy or effort.
We really do.
We have to take care of ourselves.
And if we don't,
we will pay that price.
Um,
at some point we're gonna pay it anyway.
So we're all headed to the same place that we want to or not,
you know?
And so I think hunter's a really terrifying and beautiful example of one wager
of chips that were made for the 1960s and 1970s and I think the best way to
honor that is to,
you know,
apply the brilliance that he forged and carved to the situation we have right
now with corruption.
Donald Trump,
um,
uh,
an attack on American democracy where American democracy is basically,
it's like what early on says democracy is a train and we arrive at the station,
we get off,
like they'd be basically use the ladder to get to the attic.
And now Trump's pulling up the ladder.
And I think Thompson would understand that really,
really well.
And I think reading him now,
whether you know him or not,
helps you,
and that's why I wrote free kingdom,
was so that it can be a lens on his,
his work going back or just on this present right now,
regardless of.